[Music]
chop chop
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
since i was a boy i've been head strong
always having me since i'm right and
wrong in a nutshell
detroit sucks
been here on youtube for 14 years just
busting chops and grinding
four years ago when things got done i
made me some calls and got me some
murder
yes
lotta lottery prider has gone daily
and since 2016 on election night the
club has survived
[Music]
tried to cancel us by one decree from
fox universal and nbc
we were at 40 000 people watching on
youtube and then abc decided for the
copyright strategy they couldn't make us
apologize
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so you should respect women oh
[Music]
and in the end we decided that it was
not
violative
of our policies for harassment
[Applause]
me for a long
into
time
and what do i see once i scroll past
noah and samantha bee
[Music]
[Applause]
my youtube page is
[Music]
leave my restaurant
[Music]
we don't give a
if you think this will soften us up then
youtube's got them a new laptop
[Music]
do you guys have papers
[Music]
you're here to shut me down
[Music]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
see this is what i do i do this for you
i try and subject myself to the the
sippage because the asmr freaks get
really into it do they and then
unfortunately there was too much like
with wine you're supposed to bring air
in with it right it's called turling
though it's not sipping oh well that's
affected yes so my point is that i uh i
inhaled and i did it wrong it went down
the wrong pipe glad we're with you it's
the sound of tuesday i suppose um we'll
be talking about a lot today
and brian stelter makes an appearance
as as does uh
second lunch
real journalist right yes so second
lunch second lunches not quite liner not
quite lunch
don't even get me started on dinner
that's way way better dinner is right
out we're talking about second lunch uh
and then there's third lunch and then
there's linner and then there's a two
mimosa brunch but we're talking about
that but another thing that i really
wanted to talk about is uh
the opioid crisis so first off
a lot of folks don't consider again the
collateral damage uh the unintended
consequences of keeping the borders you
know open or allowing more people of
course to come into this country record
numbers
uh the fentanyl issue right this is
something we we say that we're doing it
out of empathy because people want to
come to this country they're not
actually asylum seekers they're just
leaving a country that's crappier than
the united states that's it that's not a
reason to be able to enter here
illegally but that's a subject for
another day fentanyl has increased
dramatically and unfortunately that's
been conflated with what has now been
coined the opioid crisis and i will tell
you it bothers me just just hear me out
i have some unpopular opinions on this
especially having just gone through some
major surgeries there is a huge
difference between street drugs
and what people consider the opioid
crisis but it's a third rail that no
politician wants to touch so my question
of the day is
first off do you know anyone who has
been affected by the opioid crisis i'd
like you to comment below we'll read
some of those comments here probably
next week
i know some people who have been
affected by it
not in the ways that you may think and
it's tragic but then my question to you
also is what is your opinion on the
prescriptions
of of opiates of actual prescription
opiates to people who are you know
actually suffering from suffering from
pain or have been through major surgery
so we'll be talking about that a little
bit because i think the pendulum may
have swung too far
the other way before we get to any of
that oh i should let you know
there's a no show this thursday so i'm
telling you there's no show on thursday
for good reason and i'll be in michigan
royal oak those tickets are sold out but
the people in royal oak we are going to
see you this saturday uh no show
thursday every other day though if you
miss a show and we have not told you if
you don't see it here on youtube go on
over to rumble go to mug club we're
still streaming live monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern just because
we're not here on youtube doesn't mean
that the show is not streaming nothing
would make me happier than you guys
leaving the tube that is you and going
over to the rumble because rumbles
bounce all right gerald a is here how
are you i am well sir how are you i'm
okay doing all right yeah i'm okay
got a little bit of sleep which was nice
well that's everyone's it's a rarity it
is yeah it's hard to come by but uh
by the way he's addicted to opioids all
the time right now he's just literally
when he walks he sounds like sounds like
damn maracas i did do the show one time
uh on opioids yes
of course you did after surgery and by
that you mean you one time did a show
not on opioids no no it was back surgery
flip it you should just see what he does
in the alleyway for a bottle of percocet
and uh we have in third year dave is not
here with us today but it is quarter
black garrett
wait
it's uh
it's not black history no i know we just
thought we'd do it for you yeah
with you every month is quarter black
history month let's see what you did and
you work of course now on the youtube
channel he's not here anymore we miss
him but uh nerd erotic that's right
neurotic
and also i have a youtube channel right
where i play video games and talk about
movies
right yeah for people who want to watch
someone else that's right play video
games
do they pay you like to eat
cheeseburgers like the test holiday
stuff on webcam or like yeah
like a mukbang have you seen that you
saw that though where like the people
like that i tried
i'd like to avoid that right well you
know what it's going to cost years of
therapy also uh lot of credit.com tour
we are going to be in colorado springs
june 18th there's still some shows left
for the second show tickets left tulsa i
don't know if it's i think it's kind of
sold out i don't want it i think it's
basically it's sold out tulsa so i
apologize but uh colorado springs the
second show got a lot of crowd.com we
have a big fall tour that we'll be doing
but first before any of this time to
react to something
uh
new jersey just created a new mod what
they refer to as model school
instruction materials i don't like where
this is going uh
oh i have seen this video they asked me
to not see and not watch but i have seen
this video what i haven't so if you have
children they should leave the room even
though the house these materials leave
the house they should leave the country
even though the materials are designed
to be presented to kids
which again the whole grooming thing is
a conspiracy so here's just one video
from the amaze.org website again if you
have kids they should leave because
they'll just see this in their public
schools
watching porn doesn't make you a bad
person what it means you're curious
it's normal to want to know about sex
and naked bodies
i mean look at this guy's penis isn't it
just unreal yeah we blurred it we
blurred that whoa
what hold on why why is his uh johnson
so uh you know
large wait what are you talking about
that's
that's not that that's that is one
that's more of a you problem gerald okay
relative uh here's another
topic we're gonna discuss a college
freshman just just take take the l uh
last week
the university of chicago you comment
below does that seem abnormal to me that
just seems like yeah
listen yeah i mean i have that problem
i have to worry about the being knocked
back yeah and it's just sticking up like
a flagpole yeah
sometimes you raise it up like it poncho
yeah and at the end of the level if
mario hits the top of it you get double
points yep that's right
that was for your nerd people the video
game now that's a little old school for
them
last week
we're here here we go to brian's delter
which i just i i want him to be on the
air forever please give him a lifetime
contract cnn on lifetime and if not we
will give him a lifetime cutter we'll
pay second cnn just to host his show
there you go we'll pay for the show it's
free air time and i'll pay for it we'll
start a gofundme if we have to yes
crowdfund this keep stelter on the
shelter's like go me go fund me fund
well i guess i think he's still looking
at that previous uh the little video we
just watched i can just wire transfer
into the me and you know he's like i get
to watch this every day
i mean me in the mirror
oh my gosh yeah
i'm sorry i didn't mean to start it this
way but we live in a horrible culture so
last week the university of chicago uh
at
and the atlantic um
they hosted
they hosted a
quote disinformation and erosion of
democracy conference it's ironic that
they hosted it
boy this is where i just know this is
just really that's where i wish i could
i just did cocaine
it'd be easier to process
and uh of course so it's the
disinformation and erosion of democracy
was this international about how to do
that by the way chicago an instructor
yeah chicago how to
this it should have been how to
disinformation and erosion of democracy
for dummies conference and of course it
featured um cnn's uh heavyweight
champion
brian stelter
uh i've been assuming he makes the
cut-off weight or he still has to cut he
has to spend some time in a sauna that's
true so
a freshman student christopher phillips
lobbed this
final question
uh to stelter and um i think it's worth
watching uh hi thank you for coming uh
my name is christopher phillips i'm a
first year at the college uh my
questions from mr seltzer uh
you've all spoken extensively about fox
news being a purveyor of
disinformation
but cnn is right up there with them they
push the russian collusion hoax they
push the justice smallett hoax
they smear justice kavanaugh as a rapist
white supremacist and yes they dismiss
the hunter biden laptop affair as pure
russian disinformation
with mainstream corporate journalists
becoming little more than
apologists and cheerleaders for the
regime is it time to finally declare
that the
the canon of journalistic ethics is dead
or no longer operative
all the mistakes of the mainstream media
and cnn in particular seem to magically
all go in one direction are we expected
to believe that this is all just some
sort of random coincidence or is there
something else behind it
it's too bad it's time for lunch
of course it is you have 30 likes
there's a clock that says 30 seconds but
but i think my honest answer to you and
i'll come over and talk in more detail
after this no he doesn't when the
camera's looking you're describing a
different channel than the one that i
watch uh but i understand that that is a
tv narrative about cnn i think it's
important when we talk about shared
reality and democracy all these networks
all these news outlets have to defend
democracy and when they screw up admit
it
uh but when benjamin hall the fox
correspondent was wounded in ukraine oh
you pivoted the news crews at cnn and
the new york times stopped what they
were doing and they tried to help they
tried to help them get out of the
country they tried to find the dead crew
members that's what normal people would
do that's how they actually do work
together to your question about sharing
those kinds of connections points to
someone else they're like i didn't ask a
question yeah what are you talking about
we don't share that reality about how
that happens it's just
the regime i think you mean president
biden the president i spoke with abiding
we yelled at each other so that's the
reality of the news business that people
don't see that people don't that was
just dirty
that it's a situation that simply is not
they were listening to the screen your
question
it speaks to the failure of journalism
to show our work and show the reality of
how our profession operates
we have a lot of work to do i think
okay well i've got a blinking rap
applause
[Laughter]
don't go back in my heart don't get
close to him he gets aggressive when you
get close to his food oh gosh uh look he
ignores all of the claims this is the
and this is the this is actually a
perfect example of you know
i hate to use the term mainstream media
legacy media is they have a platform
they have a platform on television and
it's one way you know it's a one-way
platform where there's no interaction
where they can just go on there and they
can spout their information and they get
to ignore all of the actual claims all
of the actual criticisms and they just
act as though they don't exist for
example we saw this at cnn with cuomo
and his brother only when there were
actual legal ramifications did anything
happen and it's the same thing with
stealth right here you're just seeing it
happen in real time he's so ill-equipped
to deal with
not even really accusations just factual
claims about inaccuracies in the media
what does he do he ignores it he points
to the chambermaid saying your question
okay your question
and then he uses the appeal to emotion
fallacy right he's saying well
journalists are still good because uh
they don't let a fellow american from
fox they they didn't let him uh like
bleed out one time
oh okay okay that's good yeah good i'm
glad you answer the question yeah like a
human being right thank you very much oh
and then you you actually went the
opposite direction and oh by the way i
yelled at someone too it's like see okay
we help and then we yell so we can't be
bad yeah like well that didn't answer
anything and right away he's scanning
the room yeah
you're scanning the room for allies yeah
exactly it's like tom hanks and
punchline like someone help me oh he's
like
allies and even his ally on the right is
like okay
even for me that was pretty bad
brian do you want to fix that no there's
lunch there's lunch it's right out the
hallway i can smell it there's it's
second lunch he just when they're
calling him for lunch it's just the taco
bell the gong just
by the way
i have a bit of an update for you the
guy who asked that question actually
tweeted out i just saw it before the
show uh and he said uh i mean it's been
out for a while but i just saw it he
said
that brian did talk to him afterwards
but failed to answer any of his
questions of course he just asked for
his phone number now
you see him scanning the room for allies
yeah and by the way this is also why
we've been in legal battles to one
degree or another with cnn that's turner
broadcasting uh abc disney uh nbc
universal i don't know if it's cbs vox
because what happens is once they get
into the kinds of platforms you know
we're like you guys do there's there's
two-way communication to some degree
they can't compete and so then youtube
changes their algorithms to favor legacy
media because they spend more money on
advertising they can't compete on the
playing field not only of ideas but of
quality of content and so
that's why they want more government
control regulation over youtube twitter
facebook spotify because they want to
have an unfair playing field just like
big banks with never-ending bailouts so
anytime you look at the behemoths you
look at the goliaths
you look at the mojos like
stelter you do see people who you have
to take into account that they're not
looking out for your best interest so
he's scanning the room anyone going to
help me who's going to help me uh let's
contrast that with um you know stelter
the who's going to be my friend uh body
posture in in this clip time to listen
up you silly liberal fruitcakes
i came out here i wanted to tell some
jokes let's do some reality checks here
you have any idea sir how pathetic it
must be to be you these people wanted to
come out and have a good time hear a few
jokes some thoughtful discussion but
your head pops off the pillow in the
morning with oh how can i be a
professional victim today let me go in
and screw with their act just because oh
my god your parents didn't tell you that
your opinion wasn't worth that much
look look they're confused they're
confused you know why because i'm not
your gender studies professor who has to
cater to your trigger warning
microaggression safe space bullsh
oh well that wasn't brian stelter oh
that no no you guys fit that one in
there that was the classic thank you for
subjecting me to having to watch myself
ah no brian was in the audience he was
yeah yes he was he was eating so he was
happy though
totally fine
that's the only time he's silent yeah is
when he's gorging
are you making fun of an immutable
characteristic no it's an entirely
mutable characteristic just so you know
by the way you can just get richard
simmons calorie counter and it would go
a long way mojo reference that that was
okay i mean it's a bad marvel character
but you know i got it yeah evil yeah
it's a good marvel character but he but
a remarkable striking similarity to
brian stelter hey before we move on to
it's birthday time oh hey
for a super straight white sis hetero
male who's well not necessarily white uh
token owen's birthday happy birthday
token allen yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
talented man he was dancing earlier to
that
nothing yeah well that's true i just
have one comment but
that's hot
that's hot a little teaser for later
yeah
no i don't know what we'll be discussing
on mug club but uh i don't know if i'm
scared now that that's the teaser you
see we showed the village people and he
said that's hot
i'm a narcissist i was talking about
myself yeah no
no
he's like what's worse saying the
village people are hotter wait wait wait
are you
yeah yeah the village people you are the
village people he's very focused the
village people are yours now they belong
to you so
here's another story before we get to
the opioid crisis and the uh the
epidemic right now really the problem is
what's happening at the border with
fentanyl and i don't know if you notice
the cartels not really looking out for
your best interest in the cartels big
fans of the biden open not open border
but you know more open border policies
super open border but before that this
is important last week
a man was arrested uh
i'm trying to think about a a man was
arrested for servicing himself
on a southwest flight from seattle to
phoenix
four times
southwest makes sense well no for
context that's only a two hour 48 minute
flight wow
we actually and by the way i think we
actually have a picture of the man in
question we have the exclusive yeah oh
wow okay
he just backdoors it in with the asexual
that's not it at all uh let me read a
quote for you it says the man in
question is accused of masturbating four
times in the seat next
to a female
passenger the woman took pictures of the
man while he was asleep and gave them to
phoenix police when she landed i mean
she's lucky that she caught him when he
was sleeping i mean after about a 20
years asleep yeah after a 24 second
refractory period
man
that's so terrible he had time to sleep
everything is connected just so you know
you can't have
men beating women
in ncaa swimming competitions and videos
like you just saw being a part of a
school curriculum and not expect serial
[ __ ] on your jetblue flights he
just has flying anxiety in this yeah
exactly
only release yes get some sleep his
penis was his therapy dog
look it has a vest
now uh
here's the thing of course that guy
should have been punched immediately
just like the remember the detroit uh
fire crotch bomber i don't know if you
remember right when barack obama became
president there was a truck bomber
there's a terrorist who tried to blow up
detroit which is hysterical by the way
and he had a bomb in his pants the
underwear
and what happened is uh he only ended up
blowing up his nether regions and a
black guy he got punched in the face
so he went he thought he was going to
die in a glaze a glaze
back to stelter in a blaze of glory for
allah and instead he blew off his penis
and was punched in the face is he still
alive
i don't know poor unicorn could never
show his face with isis again oh my gosh
just laugh him out of the room strip off
his patch so um now he can be a female
with sports there you go yeah break all
them rules
actually surgery and you're muslim he
wouldn't be able to do the swimming
though i mean he just you can't trim the
body hair enough
too much drag yeah
now um of course look i get it this
would be a traumatic experience for the
uh lady and uh we feel badly for our
heart goes out to her uh but the woman
has been gracious enough the woman in
question to share her story with us i
believe we have her uh on uh on deck
skyping into the show here oh yeah here
she is oh nice
yes there she is hi steven hello hey uh
can can now can you hear me first off we
don't want to you to be docs but thank
you for calling in uh where are you now
oh yeah sorry i actually just boarded
another flight so i'm sorry for the
noise but i'm happy to share my story
and maybe
just like be a source of courage for
other ladies out there who have also
been seated next to [ __ ] it's
gross yeah well i can imagine can you um
can you tell us about that a little bit
you're you know you're in yes yeah of
course so i was flying from seattle to
phoenix
and maybe like i don't know like two
minutes into the flight i start hearing
this really weird like
sound and i
was like oh my god guys look
what's going on is that the same guy is
that the same guy from before that's the
same guy that's the same guy yeah i'm
not flying southwest again okay only
flying american from here on it gross
ridiculous yeah well you know what we'll
we'll pay for that we'll pay for spirit
thank you for doing i appreciate it
goodbye goodbye thank you very much yeah
i feel uncomfortable
get so fast i don't know that's service
right there ma'am can i get a blanket
please
cover myself right away that better have
been economy plus
uh extra legroom yeah that's true
otherwise i get a like get a toe cramp
there are trade-offs
[Laughter]
i'm still amazed that he had time to
sleep in a two-hour flight
four times and he slept
like a crazy like a baby that is some
skills
what in the world okay so look saying
one time would have been like enough to
blow my mind right but somebody's
sitting there
four
if i say the word
if i if i play bomberman on my cell
phone they ground the flight a guy can
service himself four times and i mean
like we're good keep going don't just at
least you know get the get the air
marshal to lock him in the back well he
he was in all fairness still wearing his
mask oh okay so that good thing was you
know it's totally fine yeah does it
count as mile high club
no not with yourself it doesn't no i
think it four times it crosses over
was this a dare like was this a bet like
all right i bet you how many times but
you can't possibly do it four times
two and a half hours how many can you
crank out let's go
guys you know what comment below uh
wouldn't you just wouldn't you just
strike him as hard as you can
can't we create a law like we'll give
you the we'll give you what we call
the grace masturbation one time no no
no no but time number two or you got an
experiment you never know
did the flight attendants come over and
like sir excuse me we're gonna have to
ask you to stop the fast and seat belt
sign is on
sir uh would you like a diet coke or
maybe some water you're gonna need me
said if he grabbed a vape if he grabbed
a vape pen if he grabbed his jewel they
would have kicked him off and grounded
the flight yeah exactly oh gosh
okay so let's move on here too
we live in a sick
sick world with sick people sick name
that movie line uh also smash the like
button if you're watching on youtube
because that helps with the algorithm
especially you know what if you want
more change my minds like yesterday yeah
yeah yeah if we don't get uh if we don't
give 50 000 likes i'll never do another
change for mine as long as i live okay
guys
do it i'll never do it again i don't
want to pressure you threaten you but
well it sounds the brakes
a little bit so let's talk about the
opioid crisis and and this is something
that i've wanted to discuss for a while
and i know that i'm going to get crap
for it
so let me be very clear in separating
the issue that we do have that we need
to address
that a huge portion of you know those in
the swamp don't want to address because
they want to conflate these issues and
have more control over medical
practitioners so
and it goes back to the dea and this is
important because a lot of people who
are against the drug war and i
understand that i agree a lot of people
who are pro
legalizing all of marijuana and i'd
certainly think that it should be
removed from the scheduled substance
list and states should be able to do
what they want with it but a lot of
these same people are then advocating
for another drug war only it's on
prescription painkillers that are being
given by physicians and i think that
that is a problem i think it's a problem
if you now give the government the
authority to pressure physicians and
pharmacies into not being able to
provide care to people uh and in some
instances opiates are appropriate in
some instances i just want to be clear
that being said we do have a serious
problem right now going on
uh as discussed i think we discussed it
um briefly last week you know the the
biden administration
they're ending the enforcement of title
42 right which is during a health a
health crisis they're able to actually
deport people right there are certain
there are certain parameters that if
they meet it gives them more control
over uh handling uh you know immigration
at the border and being more stringent
yeah he decided no we're not going to do
that so
the daily arrivals of the border have
tripled up to 18 000 per day
jeez now keep in mind this comes at a
time when seizure of fentanyl is already
at record high so there is a direct
correlation in 2019 we had 2 800 pounds
of fentanyl
2020 that went up to 4 800 pounds 2021
that went up to 11
200 pounds so you're basically talking
about it doubling year over year we
don't have the 2022 numbers because you
know we only have half of the numbers
and and of course you know they make
their killing during the holiday season
it is a season yeah yeah i think we're
already over getting a lot of numbers
for this year i don't know the exact
numbers they're not fully reliable
because they report end of year and
again they it's one of those businesses
you know it's feast or famine during the
holiday season that's when it's the
holiday season oh and by the way i just
want to make sure we understand this
like a a that little grain of rice of
fentanyl is enough to kill you yes it's
enough to kill you okay yeah exactly
sure yeah yeah yeah a pound of fentanyl
could kill all of chicago yeah took care
of a big
big guy recently yes
yeah kind of a big deal yeah but i just
yeah i'm trying to remember it seems
like it was in the news yeah something
about uh something about yeah i have no
idea it'll come to us there's a mural
somewhere so
where does most of fentanyl come from in
the united states
take a wild guess it's not a trick
question look i'm not doing this to try
and trick you
there you go
speedy gonzales
on a slow news day who would have
thought
that discussing something everything is
on board with yeah
fentanyl being bad on the street is what
gets us banned
i never knew so it mostly comes from
mexico and it's mostly made in china of
course keep in mind the fiscal year of
2021 um south texas ports they reported
a
1066 percent increase
in fentanyl seizures those are just the
seizures so you now have the numbers of
how much is being shipped across the
border you now have the numbers of the
seizures that they've increased and we
have more references available all
available at lightworkcredit.com and i
would highly recommend today that you
look at the references because i'm going
to hit you with some facts that most
people don't know three key facts on the
opioid crisis that may change your point
of view on how it's been presented and i
will say republicans have failed us just
as badly as democrats have because it's
one of those issues where it's for
political clout if anyone goes out there
and says the opioid crisis the opioid we
have to stop the opioid crisis with
these sort of general
these vague platitudes people go well
that's great i know someone who's
addicted to painkillers good this
person's going to stop it three key
facts that may change your point of view
may not like to hear them but first
let's start with fentanyl bad drug
cartel's bad open border is bad we've
had a dramatic increase in seizures just
in texas in the last few months there
have been major busts all across the
southern border
the dea has actually been working in
arizona in this area of arizona for the
past couple of months addressing a surge
in fentanyl drugs that have been found
in this area they say that all the drugs
found
could have saved all the drugs that were
found that we mentioned here earlier
this week could have saved 700 thousand
lives
this is not a recreational drug this is
death 1.7 million fentanyl pills seized
in a drug bust the largest on records
bigger than a grain of rice these drugs
misform and fentanyl which is smaller
than a breadboard for us it's what is
driving our opioid crisis not just in
arizona uh not just in this region but
across the country
so fentanyl related they're getting so
bad that the dea actually sent a letter
out to law enforcement agencies uh
warning of mass overdose events so you
don't even need to join a cult anymore
just have mass overdose events uh
fentanyl is killing americans at an
unprecedented rate tragically many
overdose victims have no idea that they
are ingesting deadly fentanyl until it's
too late yeah they're lacing it into
cocaine yeah that was one of the busts
that we we man where do you get some of
that i just want to test it out no but
why would you do that you just get off
the streets you just killed your clients
get it off the streets it's a bad
business model i mean normally you kill
them over time this is doing it really
quickly well i just don't think i don't
think so much is that they want to kill
off their their customer base just
they're not very good at math it's made
in china but it comes through mexico
there's a middleman who's not doing he's
not carrying the one they're not cutting
it right right
uno yeah
so 2021 uh there's a record number what
was it a hundred and um see i'm almost
as unprofessional i'm looking down at my
this is my prompter so i look down at my
ipad to make sure i have the numbers
right she's sitting there she's like and
there have been
10. i gotta scroll i gotta find it it's
i mean
here somewhere journalism is dying
because of trump so uh 2021 a record
just do your wreath just have the number
at you have you seen us do a change we
might have to remember so much crap
105 000 people died of drug overdoses in
2021
huge amount of which most of which
involved fentanyl for example in
milwaukee um
well i guess all of milwaukee county
they set a record for ods 80
involved fentanyl geez
and last year this shouldn't be
surprising but this is just for you know
if you're watching and you're liberal
you're a leftist uh and you still think
that covet is the um
i'm not allowed to say what happened
still think kova is a thing uh meeting a
thing as far as an actual threat right
now in the bay area uh more people died
of fentanyl overdoses than kovid um also
died from hate crime attacks against
asians than covet yeah that's a rise
it's terrible also more people died from
toasters than coveted ah vending
machines falling on yeah those last two
i can't substantiate but definitely more
people died from fentanyl than from
covid uh and fentanyl's gotten so bad in
san francisco that um it's actually it's
become now a part of just the tourist
experience these mothers have a message
and they want everyone to read it so
it's writ large in billboard form
looming over union square it says famous
the world over for our brains beauty and
now dirt cheap fentanyl we're frustrated
and that's why we're doing this
pressure where we think it
might be helpful pressure because they
want what they call the open air drug
markets shut down jackie's son is a
fentanyl addict on the streets of san
francisco so is quarries and so are
dozens of their son's friends gotta love
lawless city tyler there's kyle there's
george there's chris sarah
ringo the list goes on they all wish
they had their mother come to see them
the problem they say fentanyl is too
affordable and too available it's just
specific here because people can come
here all over the street right there
and not get no consequences here
just like why don't you just get him
just like this just like the southwest
masturbator you get him he's the
southwest master he's already he's
buckled
he's not going anywhere going anywhere
he can't get anywhere come on
so okay we've gone through fentanyl all
right so you understand that now and
that's a real problem and yes they're
lacing a lot of things with fentanyl
because it's cheap it increases the high
it's something that you can't it's
something that you can't really monitor
because it is so so potent and you don't
know what street drugs you know are
incorporating fentanyl now that brings
me to something and again my question to
you guys was question of the day what is
your opinion on prescription opioids and
how have you perceived the opioid crisis
fentanyl is a crisis
the drugs coming over the mexican border
are a crisis okay just want to be clear
about all of this but what you think is
the opioid crisis for example how it was
presented in the show dopesick and it
made me sick to watch
uh just the dishonesty that was taking
place what you probably believe to be
the opioid is not the actual opioid
crisis so we've heard about this
everywhere in the media and even from
politicians the opioid crisis ad nauseum
i'm an emergency physician and i'm going
to talk to you today about the opioid
epidemic last night we told you how the
risk of dying from an opioid overdose is
now greater than dying in a car crash
but in 2016
there were 42 000
opioid-related overdose deaths that is
115 overdose deaths every day but also
important for the country to see that
the opioid crisis affects everyone even
michael keaton even one of the biggest
stars in the world
okay
so
let me present this to you in a way that
that maybe is as
let me be as reductive as possible and
then i'll substantiate it with some
other facts and some clips
many of you believe that the opioid
crisis and this is how politicians have
presented it on both the left and the
right in the media is little johnny went
in for a toothache he got up he got some
vicodin and then he got hooked on
opioids and then it leads to an overdose
and we had doctors were just prescribing
opioids left and right and people are
now dying in record numbers of opioids
i'm going to give you three key facts
that tell you the opposite is true i
just want you to i just want you to
think about this for a second does this
change your point of view i'll go
through them but okay the facts that you
need to know opioid deaths have
skyrocketed since prescribing has gone
down dramatically nearly all opioid
deaths that are taking place are from
illegal drugs like fentanyl like heroin
and the vast majority of people who even
did abuse prescription opioids were
people who already had long storied
histories of drug abuse those three
facts
does that present a little bit of a
different picture
and especially to people out there who
are against the drug war
is there an appropriate place
for opiates for opioids and just so you
know the difference is basically opiate
means that's sort of naturally occurring
an opioid is a synthesized version but
i'm going to use them relatively
interchangeably because the media has
irresponsibly those three key facts the
vast majority of deaths right now the
opioid crisis or fentanyl and street
drugs it's only increased as prescribing
has gone down and the people who abused
the prescriptions were not just people
who walked in happened to get
painkillers these were people who were
seeking out painkillers because they had
a drug addiction problem to begin with
now if you know those three facts does
that mean we need to stop all opioid
prescriptions because i also know many
people who for example i know someone's
been in a car wreck who will never be
without pain for the rest of their life
yeah
and now they've been turned into
what would be they actually have a good
doctor who's like well i don't care what
the da wants to do but they would be
turned into a street drug addict
so if you're against the drug war
because you're saying then people get on
the street we don't want to falsely
present what the opioid crisis is so
let's go first through those
key kind of claims and i'll explain to
you why they're incorrect the first
claim you hear a lot is the opioid
crisis as a result of what what doctors
over prescribing the drugs addicted to a
combination of prescription drugs for
seven years one woman says her doctor
helped get her hooked two investigator
pam zechman reports the state is
cracking down on doctors who use their
medical license as a license to deal
whether it's wisdom teeth or a c-section
over-prescribing opioid medications to
control pain after surgery has fueled
the opioid crisis for so many opioid
addicts in this country the addiction
begins with a prescription from a doctor
one of the most important ways to slow
down this epidemic is to slow down those
prescriptions look everyone everyone has
been touched by this to you know to one
degree or another
right overdose or just someone with a
drug problem but what they just said
isn't true
i know that people
i don't work for big pharma i don't have
a sponsorship from pfizer like stephen
colbert it's just
that's not they're breaking the song
right yeah
needles we didn't write any of their
lyrics just by faster by fighter by
fizer by fizer and sketch
so first the vast majority of overdose
deaths they come from illicit street
drugs
fentanyl and heroin okay they're not
coming from prescription painkillers
uh just to be clear and also the dea is
not even being accurate and how they
track uh opioid deaths it's sort of like
death with covet is just coveted death
oh yeah someone could have 15 drugs in
their system yeah yes so uh here's
another one opioid deaths like i just
said they've actually skyrocketed
skyrocketed and that's that's true they
have skyrocketed as prescription has
prescribing has taking a nosedive wow
well it's almost like the gun issue
right so you say criminals have guns and
they kill people then okay let's take
the guns away from
society right and it doesn't work that
way because the criminals still have the
guns right you're doing the exact same
thing with opioids you're saying you're
saying doctors can't prescribe them to
people that have actual medical reasons
yeah and a prescription is a specific
way to use the drug right and then
people abuse it you're taking it away
from them
it's not going to take it away from the
criminals that are on the streets in san
francisco we just
turns people into criminals because
there's like well i've got a shattered
hip and i have a broken face right you
know a chimpanzee ripped off my face on
our red wine and xanax bender and my
doctor is afraid of the dea so they go
to the street to get some kind of a pain
relief by the way these same people who
are often pro-legalization of marijuana
they're a lot of they are the same
states that want to ban uh kratom which
is a t that has naturally occurring
opiate agonists
so and again i'm not encouraging people
out there to go use any type of
supplement or medication that's not what
this is about but as prescribing has
gone down the deaths have gone up to be
very very clear
and another thing like i just said but
references are available i'll
expand upon this a little bit the vast
majority of people who did use the
prescription drugs they already had
extensive drug histories you've heard of
doctor shopping yeah most of the time
the people who were abusing a prescribed
drug they were doctor shopping now let
me give
some uh let me give some credence to the
fact that late 1990s
early odds there was an over
prescription problem specifically of a
drug oxycontin okay and this was people
just like to blame
uh purdue pharma now they were dicks
kind of like pfizer astrozenica
yeah
not i'm far for me to trust you know big
pharma carte blanche but uh purdue what
they did was they actually got the fda
to create a label based on
inaccurate or incomplete research that
said oxycontin which is just a time
released form of oxycodone which is very
common right percocet is oxycodone you
can get oxycodone in a multitude of ways
oxycontin said since ours is time
released it's less addictive than other
opiates doctors before that all knew
that there were there was addictive
potential to opiates and so they were
very careful in prescribing them and
they would taper people down what
happened is one company
in bed with the fda got an inaccurate
label and so there was there was an
there was an over prescribing problem
okay sales grew from 48 million
i think in 1996 to 1.8 billion by 2 000.
that's a bit of growth yes
it's prescribing pills by the way 80
milligram pills is what they were up to
prescribing when i had surgery on my
back i think they gave me 10 milligram
pills was it oxycontin or was it no it
was like a percocet it was like it was
something i don't remember exactly i
don't think they're prescribed oxycontin
anymore it was like narco or something
norco is uh that's hydrocodone it's like
a vicodin okay yeah so that i think this
is a little higher yeah well it's
because it's supposed to be time release
so if it's 80 that's supposed to be 20
milligrams and it's released slowly the
problem is they didn't really take into
account that people would crush it again
that's the problem with the pill people
were crushing it snorting it getting rid
of the time release again you can't
you can blame the company and you can
blame the fda for creating a label
saying there's you know little to no
addictive potential and if you've
watched dopesick you know this story but
they just sort of scheme over the fact
that the fda did it they're like oh that
was just purdue lied to them wasn't that
the job of the fda to make sure they're
not lied to their only legitimate
purpose
should be a telling job
to inform you of the risk
if you if you believe
in complete drug legalization meaning
you you don't believe in the drug war at
all right you're you're you're anti-uh
abolitionist if that's your point of
view that the fda's only job should be
let you know what's on the label that's
what i believe yeah in other words i
don't think the fda should be able to
tell you well you can't take this
because it hasn't gone through our
process they just need to be able to
inform you as to the risks that's their
job that's how they protect you not to
be a babysitter so after this what
happened is the dea went after not just
doctors pharmacists in 2011. they
arrested over 22 doctors there were 40
pill mills is the term that's been used
that were closed now um i'll uh tell you
this too this is something i experienced
recently i went through a a major
surgery i think we have some just b-roll
from uh um oh oh my god that's not me i
can't i can't show my actual surgery oh
damn this is just the general procedure
that i went through um where they
actually you know they went in they had
to turn my rib cage around and put in
three titanium rods six that last part
where they turn it upside down yeah yeah
yeah it's like i could probably cause
something i might be able to get the
actual footage of my surgery at some
point put your hand up i just want to
see come on pull them out like i want to
see it what come on you got the titanium
in your chest and not in your hands come
on
a little wolverine i asked for the
adamantium but my insurance wouldn't
cover it
that's an upgrade yeah
something about a deductible so well
that happened okay
and then i ended up in the emergency
room and overnight because what happened
is and this was my fault i pushed too
hard too quickly to try and come back to
work uh where
they had to
i don't know if you call this a surgery
but certainly another operation they had
to drain about a gallon and a half of
fluid for my my lungs collapsed i think
this is something you guys can actually
and i warn you if you're squeamish maybe
i don't know when to when uh
when a needle becomes a pipe this is
going through the back of my ribs what
you're seeing is a has to go through the
back of my rib
all the way
to the front of the lung area to drain
the thoracic cavity here you go
lots of pressure
it looks like it's a disappearing trick
like a knife that's like a fake knife
that you stab watch watch that whole
thing is about to go in
watch
what you see me trying to fight off the
choke
at the same time trying to pop
yeah for oh that's
that was the last day of fluid
three days
and the reason why was because there was
so much fluid that built up that uh
after the first day they removed too
much and i was like i was like a noodle
because it creates this pressure in your
body cavity that you get used to so um
yeah that happened it was very
unpleasant and again this is why i would
advise to everyone listen to your
doctor's advice they they talk it's it's
partially their fault
doctors can get it's entirely it's
entirely my fault it's entirely my fault
i will say you do people
the people at mayo clinic were
unbelievable if you ever have something
wrong with you go to mayo it's there's
there's nothing even close but what
happened is they told me i said how long
until i can start you know uh like
working they said 12 weeks before you
even look at working i said okay how
long before i start walking so you're
like what about three yeah i i did it i
think i did it in eight and came back i
hope you hope you like those shows so i
said um
i said how long before i can walk so you
can walk like probably you know as soon
as you leave the hospital a couple of
days then they call me to check up on me
they go how are you doing i go i'm
getting pretty you know tired like when
i was at costco i had to sit down and i
go what you were at costco like wait a
second are you out of your mind i said
you said i could walk i said we went
from like the bathroom to the kitchen
you were at costco
i walked were you by yourself i was like
i got a cart so
those are huge cards i tore some stuff
and it created fluid but here's my point
went through that what you saw that
major surgery then ended up in the
emergency room seven days
of prescription painkillers ah seven
days nowhere throughout the history of
mankind
going back to the shootest days with
john uh john wayne and uh and gregory
peck would they give you tincture of
opium for just seven days it typical
would be a couple of months because you
know i wasn't even able to prop myself
up on on my bed yeah and just just for
reference you can actually see here hair
follicle testing um that i did within 90
days of having been in the icu and it
came back mormon as you can see
uh
because i i wasn't able to take anything
yeah and what ended up happening is do i
think that was more productive i was
just in excruciating pain for a very
long time well you had to travel too and
that was one of the reasons and then
people are so scared to prescribe this
because of all the information that's
out there and all of the focus from the
dea that
they are like no no you have to come in
we have to go through a whole thing it's
like right can you just call mayo they
will tell you i had this surgery seven
days ago please i'm just in pain yeah
right that's a reasonable thing to be
and they did they did mayo did go and
then doctors were just afraid because if
we didn't perform the surgery you know
the dea will be on our ass and i'm like
can you can you see i'm not faking it
can you can you get holes in it
this is
almost a year removed let alone i have a
i have a pock mark on my back oh from
that we were like what did you have body
acne no they said they put a metal pipe
they put a super mario sewer in my
[Laughter]
sick
and my point here is i've experienced
this personally but you did you you
obviously and you on the flip side you
did say that you took some painkillers
it did yeah and it made me feel like i'd
always had back pain and like difficulty
sleeping and so when i would take this
it actually after surgery i was like oh
man i can actually sleep and rest it was
really really nice to be able to do that
and then i realized that i was supposed
to be tapering down a little faster
based on what we wanted to do not my
doctor's recommendations right and then
i was like i i actually started like not
telling my wife that i was taking more i
was like no no i'm tapering down to like
half and i was actually taking a full
pill yeah and then i told her i was like
hey i think i think i need to stop just
like a week later wait a second yeah
she's like wait gerald are you on pain
pills again no she was just encouraging
me like hey those are addictive
yeah i'm not so so happy right why are
you listening why are you listening to
uh why are you listening to pink floyd i
don't know
it just makes so much sense to me now
no i actually cut completely off and i
started having like some jitters and
some other stuff like i was going
through with draw symptoms and she
noticed that because she's obviously
this incredible nurse and she goes hey
you can't just you can't go completely
off you have to
kind of step down and so i did over the
next like week week and a half two weeks
yeah it was fine but i could very easily
have seen like man this makes me sleep
so much better without that pain and it
wasn't just surgical pain it was just
uncomfortable doctors doctors can be
like you said it's on you you that you
tapered off it wasn't the doctors
doctors can be careless
yeah my grandfather he had chronic
severe back pain for basically his whole
life and they they were giving him so
much
uh narcotics and
opioids to deal with it and then
whenever this kind of came around
whenever everybody started turning
around and saying no we're not going to
give you this anymore they started
treating him like a crackhead yeah it's
like you put him in this situation and
let me go by saying hey take all these
pills
for a long time and not taper off he
gets used to it and then whenever you
decide oh well you know we're not going
to give it to you because you're you're
a crackhead and you just all you want is
opioids like well he's 88 and he has a
severe back problem and you've been
doing this to him for 20 years so like
what are you going to do let me guess
still has back pain still has back pain
so that's the problem is does he live
the rest of his golden years in pain or
you know what do you provide some relief
i do think that there is a relief
approach especially if you're in your
80s or 90s i would just i would just do
all your drugs and steals
let's get actual crack in here yeah it's
like if you're like you're a drug you
know well it's because of you but here's
what i would you want to say and i'll
leave you with this we're about to go to
mug club is we need to separate i think
in this country and let me know if any
of this has changed your opinion i'm not
going out here saying that everyone
should be taking opioids and i'm not
saying that doctors should be over
prescribing them but i do think we need
to separate
addiction physical dependence and habit
there are different things someone can
be physically dependent on something and
that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're an addict for example if someone
has a shattered spine and they're going
they have a choice of lifelong pain or
pain management i think that pain
management should be an option and you
obviously should too if you think by the
way marijuana is not going to work for
that marijuana will work for neuropathic
pain it doesn't work for that kind of
pain that's actual tissue damage i
believe that cbd help cbd and low
amounts of thc yes there is medical
legitimacy there are certain uses of
curl of course but someone like that
it's not going to fix it so so you're
telling me there's achievement they're
telling you there's a chance
get granddaddy thunder screw yeah that's
exactly yeah
what's the dosage i don't know just
smoke this whatever you want see what
happens so we need to separate between
uh addiction physical dependence
and habit these are different things and
again the final three facts you believe
that there's an opioid crisis now there
is a problem right now with drug
overdose deaths and the reason that the
left certainly wants to make you think
that it's the doctor problem is because
they don't want to acknowledge what's
happening in the border and the reason
people on the right don't want to
actually address the problem is because
this does affect a lot of red you know
red states for example a lot of red
states where people are in rural areas
and they do have drug problems fentanyl
has ravaged these areas but the three
key facts you need to know i want you
right now to picture in your mind what
you believed the opioid crisis to be
someone went in was given painkillers
unbeknownst to them then they became an
addict then they died the three key
facts to know
almost all the deaths come from illicit
street drugs
fentanyl and heroin they're coming over
the border from mexico largely made in
china
as prescribing has gone down like you
just discussed and like i experienced
because doctors are afraid to deaths
have gone up dramatically and the people
who actually did abuse prescription pain
killers were drug abusers by and large
they had a long history of abusing
substances and they were doctor shopping
so understanding all of that do we think
it's responsible to just throw out the
term opioid crisis and crack down on
doctors and pharmacies so that they
can't provide this medication when
appropriate to people who need it i
actually think that it's cruelty i think
that it's medical malpractice and i
think if you're going to say in the drug
war we need to take a balanced approach
to all of it and we've gone too far the
other way but that's just my opinion i
know a lot of people are going to be
pissed off you let me know what you
think smash the like button garrett with
nerd roddick thank you so much
quarterback for being here i miss you
guys we're going to mug club piss off
youtube
[Music]